the reality is most of the social that's
out there isn't working because it's
selfish you want the likes you want the
money and we don't want that you need to
put out things that provide value and
they can come in a lot of shapes and
sizes I'll tell you who I'm really
fascinated by the people who are posting
on a daily basis who have very tiny tiny
audiences that enjoy it to no end this
becomes a very simple game of why are
you doing this you do it because you
loved the thing that you're putting out
there and it's part of the process
you're gonna win the problem is too many
people want certain things and they want
it fast and that's a disaster framework
you're kind of in the middle of it right
now right we're right in the middle of
this incredible weekend that I'm sure
because I know you've put a lot of
thought into you've been excited about
how are we feeling at halftime
thank you
[Applause]
um so first of all like our organization
in the MBA
um I'm just looking around to see
Fairline
moved here like a month ago just to sit
at the Grand America
for like a month to make sure this was
going on that sounds like a privilege
the Great America's Great America is
pretty sweet and then like we look at
Caroline and everything she's doing with
the Jazz and it's just been a community
effort because you just very rarely get
these moments that you know you're gonna
be talking about like I was there 30
years ago yep yeah I was in the salt
house right here 30 years ago
and like we know we're coming at it
again and so I think we've all kind of
taken the strategy look
we're Folsom
full sin all the way up to it falls in
all the way through it we can sleep next
week
I love it I agree
um let's talk about just the Journey of
getting to this point
you know we we did a podcast recently
and you made a point uh you know I am
very loud for a very long time rape my
ambition to buy the New York Jets my
great love in sports and you talked
about being able to buy the team that
you loved
in a world where just even getting to
the place of buying a team is so
ludicrous so needle in the haystack so
one in a trillion but to then actually
get your team is it's crazy
do you pinch yourself in moments like
this
so first of all you're not going to be
the whole time
I love to talk you can interview me the
whole time I'm ready
um
first of all it's not awesome
like 30 years ago being a kid in junior
Jazz and like getting a ticket to coming
here
and like being able to be up here
um about this journey
um is interesting because just like you
with the death when we had this
conversation you can name every draft
pick of offense alignments it didn't
work out over the last 15 years and
quarterbacks there's a there's a lot of
them
but uh and
[Music]
um so look there's a lot a lot that goes
into that but when when Ash and I like
made a decision like hey and this is
what we want to do and there's so much
hurt because
you know these opportunities don't come
up and we originally had an opportunity
that was extremely rare with another
team and I was all I told the story I
was all the way down to the end and she
knew I was kind of on a solo Mission
here like full with an artist
right and
she's like what what about her Jazz
tickets
and I was like yeah what about him she's
like well
games
and I was like well no it really doesn't
work that way
you can't describe it he's really it's
like having a new child you just fall in
love and you're everything there and
she's like no
and
the next week because I kind of decided
about a two-week period the next week I
knew that like
I wasn't I wasn't getting a lot of
attention and it wasn't communicating
very well and I knew she was kind of
like hey
um awesome Fortune but this is not right
and
so I remember calling Adam saying like
this might be the only time I know
30 teams and it was super rare tiny
threading but
we're just gonna have to pass
and he's like why
honestly
because of the Jazz pass wow and and
then what happened
this isn't after I I mean I was actually
in this building and I sat down with an
event like this open slopes I sat down
the door
I'm Gail right now I got it this would
be like you're sitting down with the
Jets yeah forever and I said Gail this
was February
for 35 years
and it's not anywhere else and I said
cool you're gonna give it an incredible
job it's awesome but I had to kind of
have that conversation before I went
down the other way sure because that was
like option one this is option 30.
and
we turned it down and we just I went
back again and said hey we're going to
be the best sponsors and the supporters
of their dads do you have anything you
need from us because we're all in on the
team and afterwards too and
in July
or is that hey are you still interested
and I was like oh you guys are thinking
about carving a little bit out she's
like well it was kind of like well they
said it's kind of like the whole thing
I was like you're joking
this isn't real and then
I said yeah
that's how we're here
is like it's just a stewardship I was
with you this morning at the Utah people
know it's a little bit of a calling like
like a little bit yeah it's like we know
the responsibility of this it's as much
a Community Asset is anything you'll be
a part of this is not a money maker this
is about
doing good it's about this it's about
bringing the championship here
[Applause]
you would be saying the exact same thing
and you no no no no no no you will be
saying the exactly you will be the same
exact same thing
and I don't have an NFL team I need to
grow up to the Dolphins I'm not
available
[Music]
the joy I have
talking to your players
currently because I talked to some of
them just it's just so fun maybe
bringing it to something that impacts a
lot of us because you're in rarefied air
here there's nothing better than being
in a family of seven in a small business
of 23 in a corporation of 800 8 000
there's just nothing better than when
the top is right
everything stems from that and I think
it just really I'm very happy you know
since you're in the Western Conference
I'm a Knicks fan I have
no feelings towards the Jazz that are
negative which makes this quite
comfortable
right like the Bulls mascot came up to
me I was like trying to be you know
courteous because there was kids around
and we took a photo
but when he when the basket left I was
extremely upset
I hate the Bulls I'm four hold on let me
get this off my chest
I'm 47 years old I'm a Knicks fan 47
year old Nick fans have to hate the
Bulls
have to
do it's a rule
yeah Fair
enough
let's go but hey I have to ask you a
question okay you came over my house yes
yes
and he said five he said five yes and
you told one of the most amazing stories
to him and it was one of those moments
with my boy I was like I hope you're
listening like I hope you never forget
this because it was so organic
like it was always one of those moments
where I was like what's going on here
yeah I mean the it was we had a great
time asked the kids it was just really
nice before a game and I'm meeting the
boys and what's your name and he says
Jet and that really catches my attention
and I'm like that's amazing and then
just kind of I've met other boys named
jet through the years but this was the
first time I asked him I said what's
your favorite number and when he said
five
it was just it was just like this
incredible moment I think about a lot it
happened recently and um so for me I was
born in the Soviet Union and came to
this country when I was three and the
first couple years were extremely rough
we were extremely poor and when we moved
in 1982 when I was seven to Edison New
Jersey that's kind of when our American
Dream started that's when we were out of
like the gutter and and like it started
happening and that's when I started
really to be frank learning more English
and becoming Americanized and you know
for the raise your hands if you're under
35 just raise your hands so for you
youngsters first of all that's Epic
second of all something crazy happened
back in the day kids went outside
and so I went outside and some kids were
throwing a Nerf football
and I came over and they're like you
know my friend Eric Godfrey was says to
me what team do you like and I'm like I
have no idea and he's like you're a Jets
fan and I'm like all right we're Jets
fans you're a Jets fan
it's true that sometimes I wish they
were giant fans and said I was a giant
fan because four Super Bowl rings would
feel very nice but I love the journey
we're on I love the climb 100. that is
told by The Neighborhood that is exactly
how I became a Jets fan
that was the 1982 season I started
watching that season because this is
right before school in August the season
started in September a couple weeks
later and I just started watching and
I've never stopped but that but the Jets
tricked me that was the 1982 season the
Jets made it to the AFC Championship
game the game before the Super Bowl so I
was like this is great this is what it's
going to be like obviously we've luckily
been able to get back to that game three
more times in my lifetime we've lost
them all so that just have never been to
a Super Bowl in my lifetime but
where the story takes a turn
my friends all had Jets jerseys and I
asked my mom to get one and we were just
not buying those kind of things at that
point in our life the first seven or
eight or ten years of America was
shelter food the end no vacations no to
like we just weren't buying things and
so at night my mom while I was sleeping
knitted me
a Jets sweater a Jets Jersey and at that
point already my favorite number was
five and she put the number five on it
and so
it's just it's singularly my prized
possession when I buy the New York Jets
I'm going to take that sweater which I
have locked up in the most safe place on
Earth and I'm gonna put in the entrance
of the super of the stadium with a
little plaque that says from not being
able to afford a Jersey to owning the
whole [__] team
and I think you know I think I think a
lot of us in this room many don't my
father doesn't have this a lot of people
I know don't have this but some of us in
this room are extremely lucky to be the
byproduct of an incredible mother and
when you are the byproduct of an
incredible mother you are really
Unstoppable and so like nothing scares
me I think I can do everything and she's
you know the beacon and Seed of
everything that has worked for me in my
life and so the number five the reason
if some of you have seen my social media
the reason I put up the number five is
that's a little bit of a head nod to the
person that crafted me and that's my mom
do that
you can imagine
[Laughter]
I'm like you want to go shoot hoops he's
like let's go to the stadium
right talk to me about let's have some
fun because this is a fun weekend give
me some predictions on tonight three
points slam dunk give me give me some
observations from the first half of the
Season which player or team is surprised
the most let's have a little sports
radio fun
all right
and he looked pretty calm
and
first of all
oh sorry
if you guys all about that
and and
um
[Music]
the only thing he asked about it was hey
what side am I shooting up
you know let's just talk about that
because I think we'll like the dunk
contest is in yeah it's like interesting
because I feel like the NFL decided to
go very radical with the Pro Bowl this
year they went in a completely different
direction whether it's good bad or
indifferent they did a bunch of things
are we competing with the NFL right now
no no well that was that was that that
was that was a Razz yeah
um
no but seriously I feel like the dunk
contest knee is really worth debating
innovating heavily like I've been
thinking I remember last year when I was
at it I was like what a dunk contest
would look like if it was two people a
team to do the dunk like obviously
people brought people out and they
jumped over them and this that the other
thing but it feels like
we've gotten to a place where we either
have to like put at 11 feet or like do
something like it these kids can only do
so much that we haven't seen as fans
like you can't ask them to just like be
Superman and just stay up there the
whole time like there's only so much
that can be done
um yeah and I'm being serious I know
what you're saying and I agree with that
like and he's just incredibly
entertaining to watch but he's not gonna
do any dunk that I'm like I can't
believe that just happened
it's just too hard to do something at
this point in the dunk contest that
hasn't been done
and that was like good marketing I like
that as a as a businessman I was like
that was cool yeah I mean look listen of
course we've gotten into the Cedric
cevallos that D Brown and and Blake but
it does feel like I don't know I don't
know
yeah just exactly like you bring out
some player that used to be on the team
like it just feels hard to innovate it
feels like there there needs to be some
something like maybe a trampoline or
something yeah
over I didn't see the same thing
[Music]
Joey you've got some to-do lists this
week
tonight there's something I've never
seen before what Joey
Joey is claiming Joey get up here come
on Joey let's hear it for Joey come on
get loud
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Okay so
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
one more time for Joey
like that little Switcheroo yes sir
real quick I want to hear from your
perspective I want a little more
basketball sports stuff which team
um has surprised you most this year or
what or you're sitting at these games
you're paying attention what player do
you think took the biggest step this
year give us a little little basketball
yeah
what team or what player
[Music]
um
no the team that is probably
[Music]
and the commonality between both of
those is you you kind of really want the
regular season we got into the playoffs
and it's super disappointing right and
that's a hard that's a hard thing to
recover from and I think for us like
going back into our second year where we
were having won all the games in regular
season and getting bounced early
anything
um but then it's like how do you prep
for the playoffs and on the regular
season as much because you've got to be
healthy in our situation we knew what it
was like not being healthy and you had a
lot of injuries this year and so I think
there's a few teams there's a lot of
teams who are way better than America
right now
but because they haven't been company I
mean we're going to just finally see I
mean I don't know what is it 10 15 games
left that we're going to see a full
Warrior's roster yep right
before right we haven't seen Phoenix yet
yep I don't think we've seen the
Clippers
right we've seen Boston we've seen
um Milwaukee
but because and even they have a scary
little things
so I think it's going to be an
action-packed last part of the season
um from a player standpoint
um
I mean he went to Europe this summer as
being um
like that was part of the deal that we
did yep and so we
we saw Ventura and the confidence of
being the first option and then in fact
translates
um
for the first time in his career when
people come in the night before they're
looking at the scoutings yes he's he's
circled is number one like how do we
stop louder so I remember the first
couple of games this year where he
started going on and it was crystal
clear the other teams were focused on it
they were hitting him at every turn and
it was just twice as physical for him
and to see him be able to handle and
acceptable on those he will be able to
like run plays a highlight audience
like it's been an incredibly impressive
and impressive and then watching others
like JC step up and and you know we've
made some moves but a lot of those moves
were because we wanted to get more
playing time to understand what do we
have
what do we have
um
for the second half to really see what
we've got and
um
yeah
the Giants I hate with all my heart hey
this this [__] here okay the only thing
I want to say is
um
okay
because
[Applause]
he's here this NBA All-Star would have
been the easy thing is to say no
like it's easy in life to say no in this
situation
to Innovation the hard thing is to say
yes and you guys said yes which required
so much more work for you all but as you
Toms and it's the people here this
doesn't happen everything going on
doesn't happen and we would have been
isolated to like three events
and announce like a whole community so
the impact you're having from this and
we're going to have from this is you
know whether trying Smith or Gary or
some little kid is sitting out there
who's going to remember this and that's
what it is about
I want to talk a little bit about like
marketing okay right because
with is a little bit of the magic but
very as easy as a problem that wants to
fix it he's already playing in his head
the sweater out in front of the the
stadium and he knows where it's going to
be
um but
one of the things that we talk a lot
about is how the future of marketing and
these jobs which a lot of people are
going to be tied to are in some way in a
career especially the younger generation
and how you said you know CMOS which are
the chief marketing officers of an
organization is going to be different
than anything that you've ever seen in
with digital and everything is coming
along like tell tell me about your
vision and what you're doing with with
your businesses and how you believe
every CMO that's going to be in the
future what have worked for you yeah I
would say I was so blown away as we've
got to know each other through the years
that last part is I think there's just a
lot of enjoyment for us to see the
people that come through our
organizations go on and win to me
there's no Greater Joy than the thought
uh to be to be ran a Super Bowl
commercial that I think a lot of you saw
this last weekend and tricked a lot of
people is really clever ever and to know
that Nicole their head of marketing was
behind that work that arguably and I
think so was the Super Bowl commercial
of the year was you know brought through
the system of Vayner there's no like
greater Pride it's not the same exactly
as your children achieving but it gets
to like the close Next Level and so the
reason I said the right is that
marketing is changing so much and we're
so at the Forefront in our Vayner world
of companies that I know a lot of the
CMOS in 12 15 years are going to come
through our walls so that's what he's
referencing to to make it relevant for
everybody in the audience so many people
here whether it's to make their Barber
Shop get off the ground like a young man
I spoke to a couple hours ago or maybe
it's just because your nephew is running
for mayor of your town or maybe you just
want to raise a couple of bucks for a
disease that took your parents life
everyone here especially with the way
that the world is going is actually in
the marketing business you know as we
all know there's almost there's very few
15 16 17 18 year olds on Earth that
don't either produce posts on a daily
basis in Social or definitely consume it
right so we're in a very different era
than the radio era the television era we
are now in full pledge mature internet
era and marketing is changing
dramatically the biggest companies in
the world many of who do a lot of things
with the NBA the reason Sports is so
dominant is there's so much attention
you know it's funny you mentioned
something Joey Adam like it is
astonishing to me how much I'm picking
up what Joey's saying about the NBA I
think what Adam has done as
Commissioners since he's been here on
the shoulders of what David has done
it's pretty remarkable when you compare
it to the rest of the sporting world I
just I believe that to be true and one
of those things that they did for
example was Europe and the rest of World
in proper football AKA soccer has had
branding on their jerseys forever that
was like sacrilege in American Sports
and who did it first the NBA and by the
way in a world where we all know in here
that we don't watch that many TV
commercials outside of the Super Bowl
brand integration into the thing we're
watching the game is very important so
whether it's things like the patch or
things like social media and streaming
services actually eating up the majority
of people in this room's attention not
print not Direct Mail not television
commercials we grew up with the
landscape is changing dramatically and
yesterday I was here and I had seven to
eight meaningful meetings with CEOs and
CMOS of very large companies and I was
blown away by how every one of those
leaders has completely accepted this new
world compared to let's say 2019 you
know even in the beginning of covid
where big Brands still thought I've got
to do the big television spot and you
got to do the Big Brand campaign and so
what comes natural to many people in
this room under 25 because it's been
their entire world YouTube social video
game streaming gaming twitch like that
is now getting to a level of scale and
what we know is that there's a lot of
people in this room who now know how to
use QR codes and they're not under 20.
there's a lot of people in this room who
are not 20 who are consuming Tick Tock
every single day and so the world is
changing significantly and whether
you're a big business or whether you are
literally a human in here that wants
something to happen
understanding how to make the pictures
and the videos and the written words for
these platforms is the Battleground and
that is for me the only thing I do for a
living for the last 25 years whether it
was helping my dad's liquor store or
doing what I do in marketing review
friends or whatever I'm doing it's
really just trying to figure out where
the attention is and how to be the best
at filling that attention with
information
you're basically saying hey Lord this is
here is
the biggest CEOs
[Music]
um
and then we fast forward we're only two
years plus and
and this entire event like all weekend
you you have you your fans here this
organization is very fortunate that you
have you are a digital native you
yourself and and and that's what I think
is so exciting about the NBA
as well which is you Matt who just
jumped into Phoenix right I saw Mark
Cuban this morning working out and it
made me think of like
yeah well we're working out you know
we're trying to stay alive
um you know and and I saw him and I've
been thinking a lot about this like the
NBA ownership's progressiveness is
profound it's why the league is more
digital and like look like there's no
time machines I know there's a lot of
people here who have a lot of emotions
towards digital that I don't like the
kids on Tick Tock I don't like this I
don't like that that people said that
about the automotive
people are like I like my horse
it's true go read the articles about the
television we don't need the television
the radio's just fine
right there was you know how many people
here did not want to get email
do you know how many people here
once had a beeper and said I'm never
getting a cell phone because my beeper's
just fine
do you know how many people here debated
me only 15 years ago that they were
never gonna go to the iPhone because
their Blackberry had buttons on it and
they needed the buttons
we have opinions technology doesn't care
about our opinions it's just going to
continue to move and either we get on it
or it takes us out perfect
I've I've
um
I've been around you enough to know that
your personality
is authentic both Who You Are
just walking around when there's no
social and there's no camera
and then when you're recording like
during morning little video to the world
and when you see people and you just
tell random strangers like how much I
love you and when we're walking by in
here
and he literally stop and say hey I
can't wait to see you I'm looking
forward to it
um you've been in a positive
like
like this story
how should I act down
and who should I be and so I think that
same thing
what am I supposed to be who should I
act and it's not pulling out of
everyone's best self
you manage
to be positive and break that Gap in a
unique way that people need
help those people who are out there
going hey what's my social person and
how to make those that distance
because I see it when I'm sitting there
on them first of all I know you you're
not that person
remotely that person I I think that you
have to ask the simple question of why
are you doing it
the reality is most of the social that's
out there isn't working because it's
selfish
you want the likes you want the money
you want to sell the thing and we don't
want that
like the reality is is that the reason
people are struggling to your point the
reason people are faking it is because
people are not confident in who they are
which is a very real reality and that's
not a new thing that has been a human
truth forever
but the reality is is you need to put
out things
that provide value and they can come in
a lot of shapes and sizes
there's people like myself who've built
large audiences and we can analyze that
I'll tell you who I'm really fascinated
by the people who are posting on a daily
basis who have very tiny tiny audiences
and enjoy it to no end they enjoy it
because they just want to share videos
of them playing video games or cooking
or things of that nature this becomes a
very simple game of why are you doing
this if you're doing it because you
enjoy it and it is a hobby no different
than playing golf or sailing or skiing
you do it because you love the thing
that you're putting out there and it's
part of the process you're gonna win the
problem is too many people want certain
things and they want it fast so now
people like oh I'm gonna do this because
I'm going to become famous and get brand
deals and I'm going to be a millionaire
in a week because I'm big on Tick Tock
and that's a disaster framework right a
lot of other people spend their time on
there trying to scare and hurt people
because they themselves are scared and
hurt
right I tell people all the time A lot
of people are like I can't post anymore
the negative comments crush me and I
asked them of like do you ever think
about instead of being upset for
yourself being up being compassionate to
the person that's leaving that if
somebody takes time out of their day
to come to your page and tell you you
suck their life is horrible
don't feel bad for yourself feel bad for
them so you know for me what I would
tell everybody here is to understand
I just want to do I just want to do for
the world yep
for you to say you're not dealing with
this you're like this is what's going on
like life's great for you like and by
the way I say yeah I say
I'm sorry you feel that way but you know
nothing about my life you think you do
you don't know how I got here you don't
know what's actually happening the
biggest issue right now is America has
fallen in love with pointing fingers
the second you get into thumbs it gets
real good
when people are accountable the reason I
have no judgment on anyone is because I
know I don't actually know what's going
on in their lives
you have no idea if their mom just
called and said their father's
terminally ill you have no idea about
anything you think you know you think
you know and it makes you feel good to
judge because it's a micro release of
what you're feeling
so for me when people say easy for you
I'm like you don't you know first of all
honestly I struggle to even get into you
don't know me because I go into deep
compassion of like damn you're gonna
need to go there because you're not in a
great place I hope that gets better
you know like you know I don't post
content
to get affirmation I post content
at this point I've come to realize I'm
posting content because I just wanna I
feel guilty I feel guilty that I have
such a remarkable mother who built me up
and so I'm like screw it I'm gonna try
to do for the world what my mom did for
me and if like somebody's willing to
listen good
awesome
that video did well well that's
interesting this is where I get to win
twice I'm doing what I'm doing because
of my life my life's journey and I just
said it over here I'm running the most
Progressive largest fastest growing
independent agency in the world and so
when I'm able to use the insights of the
garyvee content or the V friends content
or the wine text content to give us
insights of the things that we need to
bring to our Procter and Gamble or our
Pepsi or our Ford client I'm looking at
the data not only because I want to do a
better when you're trying to do
something good for the world you want
all eight billion people to hear it
I want you all to hear it so I'm looking
at it to figure out the angles of the
what we call sock strategic organic
content too many people post without any
thought of what is required to make a
post do well what's the post-production
what time do you post it what's the copy
that supports it what's the first three
seconds of the video what's the overlay
image so I don't think people are
putting enough strategy into it so yes I
am looking at that but that's a little
bit more to feed the operational beast
and to give me in that back the next
video to get as many people to hear it
look they're about to kick us off
[Music]
do you know that they're yelling at us
because we're being rude because
somebody else has to say so can you say
goodbye thank you well then that's what
I'm trying to tell you we're done okay
we're finished right it's over for us
say goodbye and thank you
thank you guys
thank you
foreign